so I found this Twitter thread where
somebody started to compile all of the
awful things that people have been doing
to koroks in tears of the Kingdom the
first one is one of many that I've seen
like this since uh just a casual corout
crucifixion somebody made a coric
rotisserie machine
the amount of effort required to do that
because they would have to make the
rotisserie machine which I guess is oh
that's a really smart plank of wood with
just two sticks but they had to bring
all the Clorox all through this one
place
let's look at how they're all like
sweating oh man this one is uh
a korok being used as like the front of
a ship type Vibe this is like the first
one that you find as well
do you think Nintendo
expected this to happen
do you think they knew mankind would do
this surely they did this one from the
Reddit korok Space Program
oh no
oh no oh
oh buddy
this is just like a more elaborate
version of the same thing
oh giantly Patrice Clark Space Program
day two after adopting a more typical
rocket shaped structure I had high hooks
to this Brave korok however though extra
weight had some unexpected effects of
today's launch
oh wow
wow I wonder if
if they can go that high
they're probably pretty weighty well
[Music]
oh
did it tip
it of course is just fall into the
ground did it tip because
the korok out of the way
to the yeah I did you have to put it
right in the middle
physics man
well this one's probably having a good
time at least
that seems like it's fine for him he's
just on a little Joyride it's not that
crucifixiony because it's not a proper
cross he's just
oh
this one's a snowmobile
oh it's a rocket on the snow
no
oh my God
and also the first tweet
is a violate Geneva does this count
which I guess is a Twitter account
a catalog of violatable and non-violable
Geneva conventions in video games so
this is basically any time that you can
violate
the Geneva Convention in a video game
that's amazing Luke's carnival rides now
with the business great
what's gonna happen though
he's just gonna go really fast
right
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my God that's the worst one and
that's also a friend of mine Brandon I
worked with him at IGN that's rough but
then we have people who moved on to the
Sign Guy who says don't let the sign
touch the ground
um Clorox weren't good enough people
have to torture him too
um
[Laughter]
Amazon delivery of korok
that's really cute
[Laughter]
I'm not even mad about that one I don't
think the AI was ready for this Taxi
that's really smart you can make them
hit themselves
oh my God
I guess especially because your
abilities are unlimited you just bully
them this one's a corrupt Cannon
oh where did he even go
paddle boat design practical side is it
a lot less Wheels take a lot less
battery fans I mean that looks
ridiculous
but it actually kind of works oh my God
that is incredible
dude
this game is so technically impressive
Wild
that's so so so cool
[Music]
what what is it because he's trying to
gonna try and break out the cage is
gonna break in on him
I didn't even notice the flame throwers
oh my God
how many of them are there three
this one's so rough I have to watch it
again
oh my God
what is wrong with the Internet
I never would have thought you'd be
doing this stuff on a Zelda game in my
life dude it's been a while since his
mistakes were made okay
they've tried to build
just a really tall
sort of
oh it went too fast and the flame caught
on it
caught up to like its own it's the
no way
it went too fast and so the flame as a
trail behind dude
foreign
you kind of can't see that's so funny
first thing the marshmallows
I'm just gonna light the whole thing on
fire oh my God
no no oh
so unnecessary this one I love I think
this is my favorite creation that I've
seen yet
literally trojanoles
does it have in it oh it's got a link in
it got tracks yeah that's pretty scary
[Laughter]
that's so cool uh okay I wanted to just
have fun watching some of these but I
don't want to actually look any further
because there was one thing that I saw
on here that I was like oh I wish I
hadn't seen that
um just like an open Wild Thing and I
was like well I'm getting in some
spoiler territory happy to see what we
had inventions people have made if you
guys enjoyed this video I'm going to
make another one let me know um because
it's obviously very fun for me to sit
here and look at some of this stuff I
hope you enjoyed this video I've never
made a video like this before it just
seemed fun I wanna I'll see you guys
next time okay